the new u.s secretary of state once
again pledged to rejoin the jcpoa or
iran nuclear deal
president biden has been uh very clear
in saying that uh
if iran comes back into
full compliance with its obligations
under the jcpoa
uh the united states would do the same
thing
but there is still a great deal of
ambiguity about the new administration's
approach
sometimes officials around biden appear
to be saying the administration will
rejoin the jcpoa
as it was with no change lifting the
us's crippling economic sanctions
concurrently with iran's return to
compliance while leaving open the option
of follow-on deals to address other
issues of concern
that did seem to be what lincoln said on
wednesday
but at other times they suggest the u.s
will use its economic leverage
to strike a tougher deal before it lifts
sanctions
we are a long ways from that point
iran is out of compliance on a number of
fronts
and uh it would take some time should it
make the decision to do so for it to
come back into compliance
and time for us then to assess uh
whether it was meeting its obligations
both blinken and biden have repeatedly
pledged unconditional military aid to
israel
and the u.s embassy will remain in
jerusalem despite the occupation
and it's clear that the israeli
government understands biden will be a
close ally
we are in front of the era of a new
american administration that is friendly
to israel
and we will know how to start a correct
strategic dialogue in the near future
we will use all the tools available to
us politically economically
intelligence and security but some
wonder if the israeli government is
concerned about exactly where the biden
administration stands
they have the very real prospect of the
united states and iran
resuming negotiations at a very high
level these are things that the israelis
are trying to grapple with and they're
doing so by
in my view really kind of trumpeting up
a threat from iran that has not
changed in the past several weeks iran
meanwhile continues to reiterate that it
will return to compliance of the iran
nuclear deal
once the signatories decide they really
are prepared to abide by the agreement
if they rejoin the deal we'll do so as
well and for an entire year we kept
going forward this way
but we've always said as soon as you
return to the deal we'll return to full
compliance the next hour
in the meantime the biden administration
is sending conflicting signals
even on tuesday sending a b-52 bomber on
a round-trip from the u.s
to the gulf in a show of force aimed at
iran used by the trump administration
several times
in the dying days of its presidency shia
britancy al-jazeera the state department